hey guys Pete here today I'm going to
talk about a question that some people
have been asking related to prophecy and
the ending of the game of Thrones TV
series this video won't contain much in
the way of spoilers for current events
but if you're not caught up through
season six of the show you might learn
some things that you don't want to know
yet everyone makes sure to stick around
to the end of the video to find out how
you can get into my new book giveaway
that said let's do this so while we've
been speculating on how season seven and
eight will play out
I've been asked if Daenerys could be Jon
Snow's Nissa Nissa related to the azure
Ahai prophecy I have a video about the
prince that was promised in Azure 'hi
that addresses the prophecy in more
detail so I won't get into the whole
thing again but we do need to talk about
and look at the differences in the azure
'hi legend and the azure Ahai reborn
prophecy note that one is a legend in
the second map prophecy The Legend of
the Zora HEIs about a legendary hero who
wielded a burning sword called light
bringer darkness lay over the world and
Zara High was chosen to fight against it
to fight the darkness he had to forge a
hero's sword this is how solid or SAN
relays the story to Davos in a Clash of
Kings a hundred days and a hundred
nights he labored on the third blade as
it glowed white-hot in the sacred fires
he summoned his wife Nissa Nissa he said
to her for that was her name
bared your breast and know that I love
you best of all that is in this world
she did this thing why I cannot say and
his aura high thrust the smoking sword
through her living heart it has said
that her cry of anguish and ecstasy left
a crack across the face of the moon but
her blood and her soul and her strength
and her courage all went into the steel
such as the tale of the forging of
Lightbringer the red sword of Heroes so
that's where the idea of Nissa Nissa
comes from Azure 'hi had to sacrifice
thing he loved more than anything else
to forge Lightbringer the story comes
from a shy and the followers of her lore
specifically and therefore Melisandre is
our main source of information about it
there are other versions of the legend
from different parts of the world but I
won't get into any of those here for
simplicity and I just want to clarify
this isn't something that Melisandre
came up with herself this is a story
that's existed in the ancient books for
at least five thousand year
according to legend now the for the
prophecy of azor Ahai reborn
Melisandre describes it as such in Clash
of Kings in ancient books of ash I it is
written that there will come a day after
a long summer when the stars bleed and
the cold breath of darkness falls heavy
on the world in this dread hour a
warrior shall draw from the fire a
burning sword and that sword shall be
Lightbringer the red sword of Heroes and
he who clasped it shall be Azure 'hi
come again and the darkness shall flee
before him she lifted her voice so that
it carried over the gathered host azor
Ahai beloved of roll or the Warrior of
Light the son of fire come forth your
sword awaits you come forth and take it
into your hand so in the prophecy of
azor Ahai reborn there's no mention of
forging a sword rather drawing it from
the fire in her display on the beach of
Dragonstone
Melisandre burns wooden statues of the
seven and has standards draw a burning
sword from the flame to convince his
followers that he is
Zhora high reborn this is basically
trickery but it gives you an image you
can associate with the difference
between the legend and the prophecy the
role of azor Ahai reborn is to be a hero
that saves the world from this cold
breath of Darkness it said that wielding
light bringer once again Ozora hai will
stand against the others and if he fails
the world fails with him
so basically if this person isn't able
to defeat the powers of darkness then
humanity dies does this mean that there
is just a sword out there on fire
somewhere waiting to be found so that
the White Walkers can be defeated maybe
but I don't think it's supposed to be
literal instead I think the connection
between azure high and azure Ahai reborn
is probably sacrifice there may be an
actual sword involved but what was more
important to the whole azure 'hi forging
his super weapon thing was that he had
to kill the woman he loved in order to
be successful why do I think this well
the story takes place in a world where
magic exists and people don't really
know why so they create these religions
and related myths to explain it george
RR martin has said that
the gods of these religions are never
going to show up and play a part on the
stage in other words we're never going
to see them take an actual role in the
outcome of different things that go on
to me this means there is no 7 or allure
that are pulling the strings but rather
a series of world altering events over
time that no one has a great an
explanation for so cultures make you
know they try to make sense of these are
all aspects of the story the author is
telling so they're put there for
important reasons but not necessarily to
detail for us the exact outcome of
future events to be clear as or Ahai
reborn does not need to forge a sword by
piercing the heart this beloved so
Daenerys is not nice Anissa in a story
of Jon Snow becoming hor-aha to go
further there's also the problem that
Dany is not the love of his life that
was Ygritte and even if they meet up and
John falls madly in love with Daenerys I
don't think she would become the
greatest sacrifice for him as Nissa
Nissa was to look to the legendary azure
high this leaves a lot to speculate on
since like I mentioned all this prophecy
and religious myths that was put into
the story for a reason Azure Ahai reborn
or the prince that was promised or both
are important to the end of the story in
some capacity the gears are in motion
for something that looks exactly like
what Melisandre is five
thousand-year-old prophecies describe we
could talk about that in a different
video though so let me know what you
guys think does this clear up the idea
that maybe Jon might sacrifice Dany to
win the war for the dawn do you still
have any doubts there are some really
interesting theories out there that we
could get into so make sure you leave
any questions you have and let me know
what you think about it Azure Ahai
reborn will have to make some sort of
great sacrifice to defeat the others
please like the video if you enjoyed it
and please subscribe to my channel you
can follow me on your favorite social
media networks by clicking on the links
in the description of this video or my
channel's main page as mentioned I've
started a new book giveaway this time
when I hit 28,000 subscribers I will
pick one commenter and send them a copy
of the new 20th anniversary
of a game of Thrones I put an Amazon
link in the description so you can give
it a look if you haven't seen it yet all
you have to do to win is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on this video and/or
any other video where I mentioned this
giveaway to see how the picking process
works for the winner check out my
Dragonstone video I picked the winner of
the last giveaway at the end of that one
thanks for watching I'll talk to you
soon